[Music]
and
free money news i like free money please
give me some free
please give me that free money i need
free money submitted by
i love sean sean awesome our editor sean
connery
[Laughter]
[Music]
andrew yang is running for president
haven't heard of him
you will soon yeah i already heard him
he's all over you yeah he has a lot of
crazy policies
they're kind of cool though do you know
what do you know he wants universal
income he wants to give
everyone a thousand dollars so he wants
to give everyone a thousand dollars
a month if you're over 18. and what he's
saying like his position on that is
um people like wasn't that going to cost
the country trillion dollars
and so what he's saying is he's just
trying to shift the economy over
so instead of putting trillions of
dollars into welfare
or into um all kinds of like social
causes
we take that away and then we give that
money directly to the people so they can
spend it the way they want so if they do
need food or if they want to go to
college if they want to do whatever they
can do that but a thousand dollars isn't
also enough to make people be lazy like
people think
they are so it's just like a crazy
concept and he's basing it off of
uh like a position that martin luther
king had before and what alaska is
already doing
and it's pretty interesting you give me
a thousand dollars a month as a [ __ ]
18 year old i survive on that yeah yeah
that's everyone saying the cannabis
industry is gonna go up
oh for sure dude but it will go right
back into the economy so it's kind of
cool
that's what he says is that if you give
people a thousand dollars extra a month
they're gonna spend it which we need to
stimulate the economy
right yeah he just wants to shift the
economy over like
there's already trillions of dollars in
the system yeah he just doesn't want it
to be
like stagnant there he would rather
shift it over here and then have it
move it is a better idea because i think
instead of
instead of a lot of money going into
administration
and and politicians and in their pockets
it's actually going to the people to
spend it what he's doing is he's taxing
um
tech companies more and so the tech the
extra taxes coming from the tech
companies
who he thinks that those uh they're
benefiting the most from this advanced
technology
which is going to replace jobs for
certain people um
he's taxing them and that's where the
money is coming from to give a thousand
dollars to every citizen that's over 18
years old
oh that's awesome that would be so
[ __ ] nice man
i got an extra thousand dollars i don't
know what i don't think anybody would
complain about don't stimulate the
economy
what blows my mind is he's uh it'll
stimulate my joy dude
he's an entrepreneur first and then he
became a serial entrepreneur
which most entrepreneurs like lean right
but in this case he's a progressive
he um says that he well he's gonna he
wants to run under
yeah under the left but he he himself
doesn't put himself on the political
spectrum okay he says he's independent
but he has to go
left if he even wants to have a chance
exactly like you have to pick
he says like i can i can be honest and
the right isn't gonna pick an asian guy
yeah he's like i could be as honest as i
want
but then that's not gonna win the game
and he goes all the lessons i learned
from entrepreneurism like
i gotta win which was actually that's
kind of i think that's what trump said
he was
going right because he's always been
registered as a democrat
but then he said that yeah his chances
were better
going right with ron paul he's been uh
he was
uh liberty he was for the libertarian
party like forever
but then the year that he joined the
republican
primaries he had a better chance yeah
yeah so
he andrew yang decided to run for
president because donald trump was
elected into the office so he could see
that the way that the country was going
he said that's a a major red flag about
the direction of our country
and um like basically people are dying
to have
not politicians in office they want
someone that's gonna have their back
they want someone that's gonna
that knows how to do business that knows
how to do stuff and he says that
his like ethics are completely opposite
to donald trump
but he also wants to run things like a
business like
uh stimulate the economy you know yeah
what's cool is he's like a mathematic
to me like he does things based off of
numbers and stats
and he doesn't play the identity pollux
that the left plays
no but the thing is yeah it's like with
trump
he kind of talked about it the same way
he was like
you know i'm gonna i'm a great
businessman i'm a great deal maker you
know i'm gonna make the best deals for
america i know the best people
right he also talks about grabbing
[ __ ] too
too short you know because we had such a
radically different president from what
we're used to
you know in terms of not being very well
spoken not very
not being very diplomatic i don't know
if people want another radical change to
happen i feel like
people who kind of hated on obama when
obama was in office was looking looking
at obama now like damn
that guy was he was a president you know
it's not too bad yeah
so i don't know if people are ready for
something like another radical change i
heard a thousand dollars a month that's
all i heard that's what i heard
[ __ ] he's smart he knows that all that
people really care about his mind and
it's something
that's easily digestible like he just
says tech companies
they're taking over you know taking jobs
whatever it's like now we're just gonna
shift it the money's still the same but
now we're just funneling it a different
way and it's like
everyone gets it like oh that's already
too complicated
thousand months campaign and he's um
he's only 44 years old too so he's a
young dude
one of his philosophies behind a
thousand dollars a month is um
he was saying that like so most people
with depression or even get into
alcoholism like all the stupid
choices you make in life when you're
stressed out your iq
is statistically proven to drop one
standard deviation so you drop by 13
points so you telling me i could have
been smarter you could like everyone
everyone that makes decisions like
uh that they regret later like whether
like me and geo get in the fight and i
[ __ ] punch
the wall or whatever it's because you're
stressed out you make the stupid
decision
but he goes if i can give everyone a
thousand dollars everyone would be
that much smarter because they're not as
stressed out and so they
may not drink and drive or they may not
do whatever they need too much credit to
people
he doesn't know how [ __ ] dumb
americans are agree 100
because that's like me when i'm hungry
and i go shopping
and i buy 400 worth of protein all right
which i did last week so the some of the
people
in the opposition what's interesting is
that he's also getting some of the trump
fan base
on on board so they're gonna [ __ ]
follow a ching chong
like that because some people he ain't
but i like his ideas
sometimes people are like i voted for
obama it didn't work out so i voted for
trump because i wanted it to work out
and now i'm just waiting for someone
who's just gambling
you know one of the you know what you
know you know one of the biggest reasons
why trump
won though is because during the whole
obama
administration the people who did vote
for him which were blue-collared
americans
felt neglected yeah so out in california
they paint trump supporters to being
these dumb rednecks right
but in reality they're not racist
they're just like blue-collar guys
that so when trump comes into your state
and says we're gonna bring call back
they go oh [ __ ] a politician that's
actually trying to do something for me
yeah
and i voted for obama thinking that he
would do something he didn't do anything
and hillary didn't go and campaign to
those people
because she didn't think they were
important yeah so andrew yang is
actually doing
what trump did he's going to these poor
communities
truck driver communities whatever that
are losing their jobs and he's saying
[ __ ] like
hey your jobs are going to be automated
by tech companies so this is what we're
going to do
so he's not sleeping on the population
that feel neglected
right yeah but to be fair same thing
happened under you know george w's
administ
or his presidency he did the same thing
promised certain things to those
blue-collar workers
neglected obama neglected and then those
people got fed up and they're like
enough is enough
we want somebody just like liars yeah
and they thought donald trump is kind of
a wild card for that right he's not a
politician he's a businessman
maybe this guy can really help us out
but
pretty much same [ __ ] i think it's time
to put a comedian in there hell yeah
dude see what the [ __ ] happens at least
when he [ __ ] up he could go
just kidding and then it's all it was a
big joke
yeah exactly that coal mining thing is
pretty funny though because like a lot
of co-workers like he's gonna bring it
back yeah i'm gonna bring back a finite
resource dude
use your [ __ ] head jackass one policy
that i think he is tripping on is uh
he was saying he wants to find the any
gun company a million dollars
if someone dies by that gun illegally
oh that's not their yeah i'm like that's
law enforcement
then then find the tech companies for
you know yeah for the hacking yeah for
hacking or whatever so that part when i
heard that i'm like you're kind of
tripping andrew gang
yeah he said that just a little bit much
thousand dollars though
i'm like take my gun i'm like i'll still
i'll probably vote for you because one
we got the same skin color and eye shape
yeah and a thousand dollars that's
pretty cool you yellow skin almond knife
[ __ ]
some people are saying that they're
worried about uh like
if you tax the tech companies they're
just gonna pass it on to the consumer so
everything's gonna be more expensive
anyway so it doesn't matter
that you have an extra thousand because
everything's gonna be more expensive
some people are saying that
other people are saying or they'll move
out like car companies did
yeah exactly they'll go overseas um
people are like trying to
argue the semantics of amazon operating
overseas though because how would you
get the delivery there on time but would
not happen
yeah so um there's that there's also
people that are like if you just raise
the minimum wage to 15
an hour that would actually give us way
more money um
to spend right yeah so that's the bernie
people yeah and then but then you put
the burden on the businesses and the
business costs more now yeah yeah and
now the your goods cost cause you
already do that within la
i think by 2020 they're trying to make
it what was it like i'd rather get a
thousand dollars
untaxed than [ __ ] get 15
because you're still getting taxed on
that 15 yeah plus this is an addition to
your income this is not meant to replace
your income this is like
you go out and work and get a job and
have and here's an extra thousand
dollars
people just want you to earn instead of
like getting something for nothing
the other people the other thing people
are saying is like they're talking about
taking away the welf
welfare programs in in exchange for this
i don't know because i see the welfare
program as hush money like people are
like oh they need to [ __ ]
work and whatever i'm like sure but do
you want to teach them the work
and do you want to motivate them to work
do you want to [ __ ] do all that
to me it's more like hush money just
just
just let them you know eat before they
commit a crime or doing something
crazier
because they don't have money but that's
my philosophy i don't know how this
stuff works i feel like no matter what
you plug and play
there's something else that offsets it
that causes something oh yeah you've got
to pick the lesser of the two evils all
the time when you think about it it's
way 300 million people right not
everyone's gonna act the same in in a
group
yeah not everyone's gonna do that and it
takes a while for things to change like
you were talking about in a different
video
like we used to work seven days a week
and we used to work 12-hour days and new
standards
it's weird to think of that now i mean
libya was a
basic basic income state and a lot of
oil rich com
countries can do that like so for
example alaska they can do it because
they're hella oil rich
right so all the residents there get a
monthly
or whatever they get money tech is the
new oil here
yeah well when gaddafi was in power in
libya
a lot of the citizens there during
college if you wanted to study abroad
they it was state-sponsored they'll pay
for that education if you want to go to
america or whatever and then they'll pay
for your
living expenses as well wow and it was
like the highest literate
country in africa at the time keep in
mind this is the same person that
watches the snow white and
seven doors
that's how i was laughing i was like joe
the poor historian is also a genius on
another level
but that's the same for you too this
moment earlier was talking about the
size of the [ __ ] carotid artery but
he doesn't know that a [ __ ]
vagina has two holes
you guys are [ __ ] the same
[Music]
you